طيب سلطان نبدا بتوقعات نسب اشغال فنادق
مركزيه مكه خلال الشهر الفضيل والتسهيلات
التي تتم هناك لاستقبال المعتمرين من
الخارج
بالفعل عاده المنطقه المركزيه المقابله
للمسجد الحرام هنا في مكه المكرمه الى
ارتفاع نسب الاشغال بنسبه تصل الى خمسه
وتسعين في المئه رغم من نحن في الاسبوع
الاول من شهر رمضان اذ عاد الحرم المكي
للتشغيل الكلي بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه
الى ما قبل جائحه فيروس كورونا نعلم انه
في المنطقه المركزيه المجاور للحرم المكي
التي تتشكل من عدد كبير ومجموعه من
الفنادق والغرف الفندقيه تتحدثنا نتحدث عن
18 الف غرفه فندقيه متواجده في العاصمه
المقدسه وكذلك المنطقه المركزيه المقابله
للحرم المكي ناهيك عن عدد كبير من الاسواق
الشعبيه والاسواق التجاريه التي تشهد
اقبال كبير من قبل المعتمرين والمصلين
الذين عادوا بشكل ملحوظه بشكل كبير جدا
الى العاصمه المقدسه وتحديدا الحرم المكي
بعدا اعلنت الحكومه السعوديه عن تشغيل
الحرم المكي
الطاقه الاستيعابيه منذ اول ايام رمضان
وحتى اليوم نتحدث انه شهد الحرم المكي
اكثر من ثلاثه مليون مصلي ومعتمر ادوا
مناسك العمره وكذلك المصلين قاموا باداء
الصلوات وتحديدا صلاه العشاء والتراويح
كما يظهر امامكم في الكاميرا سلسله من
الفنادق العالميه والشركات السعوديه
الفندقيه هنا في مكه المكرمه وتحديدا في
المنطقه المركزيه تشهد نسب اشغال كبيره
تصل الى خمسه وتسعين في المئه جميعها
ممتلئه
فيما يتعلق بالحجوزات القادمه وتحديدا
نتحدث عن العشر الاواخر من شهر رمضان هي
ممتلئه ومحجوزه بالكامل اما فيما قبل
العوام الماضيه لما كانت نعيش جائحه فيروس
كورونا كانت نسب الاشغال لا تتجاوز
السبعين في المئه على كل حال وانت تحدثنا
ايضا يعني نود التنويه والتذكير بانه في
كل عام تخرج مشاريع تنمويه وايضا مبادرات
فيما يتعلق بمنطقه الحرم المكي اليوم
نتحدث عن مبادره خدام الحرم التطوعيه التي
اطلقتها السعوديه لخدمه كبار السن وايضا
اشخاص ذوي الاعاقه سواء في الطواف وايضا
في المسعى هل من تفاصيل حولها اليوم
منظومه العمل التطوعي هذا العام هي منظومه
موسعه وكبيره وتم فتح باب التسجيل
المتطوعين من شتى مناطق المملكه للعرم
للعمل في الحرم المكي طوال شهر رمضان
نتحدث عن اكثر من ثمانيه الاف متطوع تم
تسجيلهم رسميا للعمل داخل الحرم المكي
لخدمه او التطوع لخدمه المعتمرين المصلين
في ثمانيه عشر مجال مختلف من ضمنها مساعده
كبار السن وذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه لاداء
مناسك عمره وتحديدا في صحن المطاف وكذلك
في الادوار العلويه الخاصه بالصفا والمروه
لمساعدتهم كذلك نتحدث عن الجانب الصحي وهو
جانب مهم هنالك فرق تطوعيه تتمركز بجوار
صحن المطاف لتقديم الاسعافات الاوليه
ومعالجه الحالات البسيطه مثل الاصابات او
الحالات الاصطدام او الجروح او كذلك
ارتفاع ضغط الدم او حتى ارتفاع السكر
نتحدث على كثير من المجال التطوعيه ايضا
يتحدث على وجود المرشدين والمتطوعين في
اداره الحشود لمساعده رئاسه شؤون الحرمين
في تنظيم عمليات الدخول والخروج كذلك
عمليه التطوع في السوبر الافطار الرمضانيه
نتحدث على طوال تصل الى مئه كيلومتر من
الاطوال الخاصه بسوبر رمضان هذا العام
التي يعمل عليها الجمعيات التطوعيه وكذلك
فرق التطوعيه داخل الحرم المكي
لمساعده المصلين المعتمرين وتقديم وجبات
الافطار المجانيه كذلك وجود مواقع اخرى
مخصصه لمساعده التائيين وارشادهم الى الى
اصحاب الفتوى في الحرم المكي كذلك الاجابه
على الاستفسارات الخدمات المكانيه على
سبيل المثال قد يصل شخص لاول مره الى
الحرم المكي لاداء المناسق قد يستفسر عن
النسخ او يستبسل على بعض المواقع او حتى
المداخل يستطيع هؤلاء المرشدين المتطوعين
الذين يتواجدون في داخل المسجد الحرام
وحتى ساحاته لتقديم الخدمه لهم واصاله من
المواقع المطلوبه كذلك وجود المتطوعين في
عدد كبير من المصليات كذلك نتحدث على خدمه
اصحاب
ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه وتحديدا الغير
مبصرين او غير
السم والبكم تحديدا نتحدث عنهم هنالك من
يقوم بقيادتهم وايصالهم للمصليات او حتى
الى دورات المياه
شرح كافي ووافي شكرا جزيلا لك من مكه
المكرمه مراسل مساء العربيه سلطان السلمي